las personas que tienen afecciones
pulmonares como el asma o la epse a
menudo toman sus medicamentos mediante
el uso de un dispositivo manual llamado
inhalador de dosis medidas md y por sus
siglas en inglés con un espaciador
un inhalador de dosis medidas rossi el
medicamento por la boca para que pueda
llegar a las vías respiratorias
si su inhalador no se usa de la manera
correcta es posible que parte del
medicamento quede en la parte posterior
de la boca y no llegue las vías
respiratorias donde se necesita
este vídeo le mostrará los pasos
generales para usar un inhalador con un
espaciador de manera correcta
es importante seguir las instrucciones
que trae su inhalador de dosis medidas y
espaciador
un inhalador de dosis medidas tiene tres
partes principales la tapa de la
boquilla
la boquilla
y el contenedor del medicamento
un espaciador logra que llegue más
medicamento a las vías respiratorias
el espaciador se adhiere a la boquilla
del inhalador
y también tiene una boquilla y una tapa
antes de usar el inhalador de dosis
medidas retire la tapa de la boquilla y
agite el inhalador
a continuación retire la tapa del
espaciador y asegúrese de que esté
limpio adentro
si esta es la primera vez que usa su
inhalador o si no lo ha usado durante un
tiempo tendrá que llevarlo antes de
colocarlo en el espaciador
lea las instrucciones para saber cómo y
cuándo hacer esto con su inhalador
conecte el espaciador el inhalador
cuando esté listo para usar el inhalador
póngase de pie o siéntese derecho
respire hondo y exhale completamente
para vaciar los pulmones
ponga la boquilla del espaciador en la
boca entre los dientes y por encima de
la lengua
a continuación cierre los labios
alrededor de la boquilla para formar un
sello hermético
presione firmemente en la parte superior
del inhalador para liberar una bocanada
de medicamento en el espaciador y
respire tan lenta y profundamente como
pueda
si escucha un silbido está respirando
demasiado rápido se recomienda que
contenga la respiración y cuente hasta
finalmente exhale lentamente por la boca
si su dosis de medicamentos requiere dos
inhalaciones puede que tenga que esperar
antes de tomar la segunda inhalación
siga las instrucciones que trae su
inhalador para saber cuánto deberá
esperar entre inhalaciones
después de usar un inhalador de
esteroides enjuagues de la boca con agua
y escupa la
es importante limpiar el inhalador y el
espaciador para que funcionen
correctamente
lea las instrucciones de su inhalador y
espaciador para ver la manera correcta
de limpiarlos
el uso adecuado del inhalador de dosis
medidas puede ayudarle a controlar los
síntomas de su afección pulmonar y
mejorar su vida diaria por lo tanto si
tiene preguntas sobre el uso de su
inhalador hable con su proveedor de
atención médica o farmacéutico